political analyst brit hume good evening
britt you know sometimes we
overread these races that happen before
a midterm or before the next election
sometimes they are in fact canaries in
the coal mine what about this one
well this is texas after all a
republican state and this is a district
that has been held by republicans for a
long time
mitt romney however carried it by 12
points
back in 2012 and donald trump lost it
this time
or carried it excuse me by only three
points so you get the idea that has been
trending bluer
over time as karl rove suggested um
so it's understandable why democrats
might have felt under the circumstances
with their new president seemingly doing
well in the polls and so on
uh that their candidates might have done
better but they didn't they didn't you
know they didn't come close
um so i think that's if i were if i were
democrats looking at the state of texas
i would be thinking oh maybe we're not
doing so well down there as we thought
so
yeah i think there's there's reason for
democrats to be concerned by this
you know there's another election it was
a school board election in south
lake a suburb of dallas fort worth and
the issue there
was this curriculum the 1619 project
that we've heard so much about senator
mcconnell and other senators wrote to
the education secretary a letter
saying the campaign to quote reframe the
country's history understanding 1619
as our true founding has become infamous
for putting ill-informed advocacy ahead
of historical accuracy
americans do not need or want their tax
dollars diverted from promoting the
principles that unite our nation
toward promoting radical ideologies
meant to divide us one of the founders
was on tv today take a listen
no this isn't a project about trying to
teach
children that our country is evil but it
is a
project trying to teach children the
truth about what our country was based
upon
and it's only in really confronting that
truth
slavery was foundational to the united
states
in this one election 70 percent voted
for the parents who are against this
effort
does this motivate voters well you one
senses brett that this
critical race theory in the 1619 project
that is associated with it
uh with all of its emphasis on the evils
of slavery which
we know after all we did fight a war
over and and
eventually ended slavery is has gotten
very deep into the teaching in our
schools across the country
and parents may have been slow to wake
up to this but they're they seem to be
awake now certainly the
the voters in that south lake uh texas
community were
awake to it and they voted out school
board members
that had gone along with this stuff in
favor of two who said they would not so
i think this is
this is a sign that there's a backlash
coming against this and it could be
nationwide
uh obviously we'll have to see but
something's happening out there on this
issue and it doesn't favor those who
believe that america is a racist country
and that white supremacy is
is what is what dominates here you know
we saw that with common core
which actually ended up being a major
election issue for some
republicans about education changes
yeah people are very sensitive to what
their kids are being taught
and you know educational innovation is
always welcome as long as people don't
look at it and say this doesn't make any
sense
and i think americans as a whole may be
tired of being told continually
that many of them are white supremacists
that this is a racist nation
that slavery was the founding moment of
our country and all the rest of that
and the reaction of that is not likely
to be favorable to those who have
supported those ideas and i think this
is just one example of that
all right brett as always thank you you
bet hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else